ما هي هذه الرموز والاشارات على المنتجات
الغذائيه التي يجب ان لا نستخف بها ابرزها
حرف e اي ان المنتج يحتوي على مواد حافظه
مصنعه ولها اثار صحيه رمز الثلج على
الاطعمه يدل على وجوب حفظه دوما في
الثلاجه حتى لا يفسد او يسبب حالات تسمم
غذائي الطعام الخالي من المواد المعادله
جينيا وهي جي ام او فري اي دون مواد
كيميائيه وهو من الاطعمه الصديقه للبيئه
علامه خالي من الجلوتين للاشخاص الذين
يعانون من حساسيه الجلوتين اشاره خالي من
السكر خاصه بالاشخاص الذين يخضعون للحميه
الغذائيه ولمرضى السكري ايضا اما علامه
الرمز الاخضر اي المنتج نباتي خالي من اي
مكون حيوان المصدر امر مهم للنباتيين
اخيرا رمز سي اي يدل على ان المنتج مطابق
للمواصفات الاوروبيه ومعايير السلامه
ومتطلبات حمايه البيئه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات